now we've got an update on the story
we've been following for a while now a
man facing a return to prison for a long
ago crime after he thought he was
cleared crossy green is his name he was
convicted of murder back in 1990 and he
was sentenced to death but in 2018 a
federal judge throughout that verdict
and then green was released but a higher
Court reinstated the conviction last
year Greenhouse the Supreme Court to
consider his case and on Monday without
comment the court said no it's a lot to
follow here but Aaron Moriarty has
covered this case for years and she has
Green's reaction
I love my freedom the freedom I had in
the last two years
it's been wonderful in an emotional
press conference Monday 65 year old
Crosley green insisted he wasn't angry
at the possibility of returning to
prison for a decades-old crime he says
he didn't commit I'm able
to keep fighting green spent 32 years in
prison 19 of them on death row for the
murder of a young Florida man named
Charles chip Flynn although there was no
physical evidence tying him to the crime
green was convicted by an all-white jury
that decision was overturned when it was
revealed that prosecutors withheld
evidence that officers first on the
scene suspected Flynn's girlfriend of
shooting him but Florida's attorney
general appealed the ruling and last
year an appellate court overturned it at
the time green remained optimistic that
things would work out you still have
faith that the system is going to get it
right eventually of course I'm not going
to give up my faith you know what I'm
saying I came too far I know
he is
not guilty Greene's family was visibly
shaken Monday by the Supreme Court's
decision not to consider his case and
his son begged Florida Governor Ron
DeSantis to Grant his father clemency as
a last resort please look over this case
don't just
sweep this up under the rug green for
his part
urged his family to stay strong I'm
still here with you no matter what I'm
always be with you this family would
never be torn apart
no matter what for CBS mornings I'm Erin
Moriarty
this is such a heartbreaking story and
all we have is based on Aaron's
reporting you just want somebody to look
at the case a couple of notes she sent
about this back in the day crossy green
was offered 10 years in prison he was
offered a plea deal but he refused to
admit to something he didn't do instead
he spent 32 years in prison so after 32
years he's now eligible for parole but
all parole boards want to see you show
remorse he says I can't show remorse for
something I didn't do yeah so and now
here's another here's another twist the
Supreme Court didn't hear it so now he
could possibly go back to prison it just
makes no sense you come to the
interesting question of whether Governor
Ron DeSantis will step in you know he's
got a memoir out today he might be
running for president at some point he
wants to be in the headlines this is the
case you could take a look at certainly
and the family's just saying please
Governor take a look yeah take a look at
the case before a man who can clearly
hold a grudge against the system yes he
still has faith in it it's amazing I
love that